si selon un résident chez de pâques
[Musique]
et là arrive le moment tu dois arriver
il le truc ya quoi une tête quoi c'est
pas si vous imaginez le cataclysme si tu
viens on va tous défoncés
quel dommage et là je déclenche une mon
accouchement rendement je le jure c'est
une serre dresser la table de la maison
et si ça va mais je sens que j'en ai un
[Musique]
bateau jonathon komack ont-ils soir elle
est incroyable ok mais après je raconte
mon histoire c'est celle de fiennes saut
et franchement c'est un truc de dingue
d'accord dans mon histoire vous désire
déjeuner c'est gentil merci monsieur
dans mon dos mais on a une choucroute de
la mer sur son livre simple après flic
un peu me mettais en 6 merci au revoir
donc dans mon histoire je attendre
secondes c'est peut-être important
les garçons ça va de koné garcia suis
tellement fan donc dans mon histoire
en fait ça va encore nous donne raconte
une histoire de ouf apparemment ils en
viennent à commencer donc si tu peux moi
pareil hier j'ai vu julie gayet la wells
et ses amis aiment raconter une anecdote
mon poste j'ai pas dormi de la nuit
oui il arrive on t'appelle on
t'appellera quelqu'un m'appelle il
arrivait juste là ils n'arrivent pas à
exclure que je parte avec tes signal
mais pas du tout pas du tout tu peux
rester donc je te disais dans mon
histoire
bon j'ai vite je dois retrouver cyprien
c'est une urgence il ludovic tu as une
minute j'écoute ton histoire mais il
faut que tu sois court et concis
donc
excusez moi il est midi comme chaque
jour à la même heure nous allons
observer une minute de silence en la
mémoire de johnny hallyday ou nous
manque tellement
[Musique]
vous